This is really funny.
We spoke we've been speaking this week and
we're going to speak again, in fact, about
how the world is increasingly ignoring Donald
Trump.
Media outlets are focused on the Biden transition.
World leaders are welcoming Joe Biden as president
elect, despite Donald Trump not having conceded
the election.
This is just amazing.
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson, who
I'm not a fan of politically, to be very clear,
Boris Johnson yesterday started referring
to Donald Trump as the previous president,
even though Donald Trump still does have a
couple of months left in his presidency.
And also said it was refreshing to speak to
President elect Joe Biden, which is just perfect
and hilarious.
And if you if you adjust for British humor
and British temperament, talking about it
being refreshing to speak to Joe Biden, referring
to Trump as the previous president, it's pretty
spicy stuff.
Let's take a look.
And also really funny that the statement from
Boris Johnson was in response to a question
from Labor MP Angela Eagle.
And in her question to Boris Johnson, Angela
Eagle couches Trump's refusal to concede and
as embarrassing and dangerous to American
democracy, both accurate.
But that's the premise.
And nobody even thinks to argue with the premise
because, of course, it's accurate.
Take a look at this.
The prime minister spoke for many of us when
he took a call yesterday to congratulate President
elect Biden and Vice President elect Harris
on their emphatic win in the US presidential
election.
So does the prime minister now have any advice
for his erstwhile best friend, President Trump,
who's continuing refusal to accept the result
is both embarrassing for him and dangerous
for American democracy?
Prime Minister?
Well, Mr Speaker, I had and have a good relationship
with the previous president.
I do not resile from that.
Is it the duty of all British prime ministers
have a good relationship with the White House.
But I'm I'm delighted to find the many areas
in which the Biden the incoming Biden administration
is able to make common cause with us.
It's just hilarious how Donald Trump hasn't
even conceded.
But in either case, Trump does have the presidency
for two more months.
And the British prime minister is referring
to Trump as the previous president and calling
his conversation with the president elect,
who Trump still has not acknowledged as refreshing.
Now, he may not have meant much by it, but
it's poetic in that much of the world already
is thinking of Trump as the previous president.
Trump is doing no presidential things.
Trump has not done any actual presidential
work for months now.
He's been campaigning for months.
Now he's sulking in his office, calling allies
and friends and seeing can anybody give me
any encouraging or good news?
And we'll be reporting on that a little bit
later based on Philip Rucker's great reporting.
But world leaders are just moving on.
And I was actually thinking that all of these
discussions about could Donald Trump execute
a coup?
How might Donald Trump execute a coup?
All of that which we've been talking about.
I still maintain my position that the answer
is a simple no.
The latest claims, including from Peter Alexander
from NBC, are that even Trump knows excuse
me, even Trump knows that he has no shot at
this coup, but that one of the things that
will make it even tougher to steal the White
House if Trump tried is that the world is
already looking at Joe Biden as if he's president.
But ultimately, Trump failing to steal the
White House will still have a big impact because
Trump could still delegitimize Biden in the
minds of the young al Qaeda types, as we call
them, all over the country, such that they
remain angry throughout Biden's presidency.
And obviously that carries with it significant
risk.
I don't think Trump has a master plan.
I don't think Trump is some kind of evil genius
where he's trying to radicalize his supporters
to never acknowledge Biden as the rightful
president and maybe even Duva violence or
whatever.
I just think Trump doesn't want to lose.
But Trump continuing to do this, even if he
doesn't believe that there's a shot at overturning
the election, which the latest reporting is,
he doesn't really believe it.
There could be a significant holdover impact
beyond January 20th in.
As I referred to earlier, Trump has already
convinced 86 percent of his voters that Joe
Biden did not legitimately win.
That is stunning.
And so Trump's plan simply is an ego narcissism
plan.
It's the same playbook he's used his entire
life, never mind his entire presidency, blame
other people, deny that you failed, never
apologize, never admit defeat, divide people,
get people mad and scared and angry, exaggerate
everything.
That's his plan.
But it can have an impact on his followers
and world leaders.
Dealing with Biden as president elect is a
good thing to push back against that, although
it's not like Trump supporters are really
willing to see reason right now.
And unfortunately, I mean tragically for the
country, many of them are never going to see
reason, which is why it's important that Joe
Biden do everything he can to just move ahead,
appoint adults to positions of power.
And that's exactly what Joe Biden announced
last night with his chief of staff.
And I want to talk about that next.